this is how you make a katsu curry
Burger
this is so good to make the Japanese
Curry add your oil and add our onion
your garlic ginger pinch of salt
I have paprika for color a bit more oil
the Japanese curry powder this is the
curry powder I use toast this for a few
minutes butter and our flour we are now
making a roux toast the flour for a few
minutes then add your grated apples and
your water I'm gonna add a chicken stock
Cube we're gonna transfer it to a
blender blend until nice and smooth back
to the pot finish it with soy sauce
Worcestershire sauce and honey to make
the katsu Patty mix all the ingredients
listed above
[Music]
straight to the regular flour then into
the batter then the Panko and this is
ready to fry
I'm using a potato roll keeping Mayo the
cutest lettuce you'll ever find tomato
katsu Patty now that is beautiful